this is exactly what I've explained with
the social media crisis here's a young
Manny's gen Z
he's probably what
he's how old is he he's probably 20
something years old so he's eight or
nine years old 2008 2009 perhaps
that was the time when the only things
you'd get on your social media feed was
police brutality videos
so these little kids sat up for Facebook
for the first time and it's their first
view of the whole world in a single
picture and they get nothing but police
brutality on Facebook companies were
making massive money off of this he then
grows up in an environment of BuzzFeed
my Covington post advice saying the same
thing over and over and over again and
he genuinely believes as he's older
there is a current Holocaust against
black people going on why don't people
care then he decides to debate it and he
tells people that he genuinely believes
he said that 20 to 30 percent of black
people are killed every year